what if you could elastically combine
both Quantum and classical computational
resources to accelerate the development
of real world applications you're
interested in
in this video we're going to be talking
about Quantum serverless which will
hopefully enable you to do this
if you've looked at IBM's development
roadmap you'll have seen the term
quantum serverless
what this is is just a
development model that lets you
seamlessly leverage both classical and
Quantum Resources so if you have
a cloud
with both
existing classical resources like CPUs
and gpus
and then also have Quantum Computing
resources
what Quantum serverless lets you do
is leverage the same interface
to
orchestrate and provision on demand
these different kinds of resources
why this is important is if you look at
most near-term applications of quantum
Computing are you there a hybrid model
where they take a Quantum circuit or a
Quantum program as an input into a
quantum computer
and then take the output of that
into a classical computer
that runs a classical optimization
program
and feeds back to the next iteration of
the loop from that optimization program
the problem is to solve real world
problems current quantum computers
aren't powerful enough
this is where something like Quantum
serverless could hopefully help in the
future
where we can take a distributed workflow
where we take different kinds or
multiple CPUs
gpus
and even Quantum Resources
to hopefully
accelerate development of real world
applications
of potential future use case for this is
something called circuit knitting where
if you had a Quantum program
that was too large
for today's Quantum devices you can
split it
into smaller
Quantum programs
that are runnable on today's devices
and then you
combine them with classical processing
to simulate what the original circuit
would have been
the problem with this is It's incredibly
computationally intensive to do this
process so something like Quantum
serverless will help us accelerate what
we're able to do with current devices to
hopefully develop better Real World
applications sooner
Quantum serverless is not currently
available but keep an eye out for new
developments and the introduction of
quantum serverless
in the meantime you can leverage kiskit
runtime to get started with running
programs on quantum computers
if you have any questions please leave a
comment below and don't forget to like
And subscribe